cameron is back now with a major life
change for a Backstreet Boy Nick Carter
and it's you know it does not get any
bigger than this just last month Nick
became a dad so I've visited Nick and
his wife at their home outside of La and
see how fatherhood has changed him and
let me tell you I was in for a surprise
oh look at you well really calm really
calm is a 30 hour labor homebirth
8 pounds 11 ounces right 20 inches he
was long 20 boy yeah tell me about the
significance of that beautiful name all
right well we've been watching the show
Vikings a lot and obviously Odin is very
powerful name and Odin reign Carter I
wouldn't have wanted to name him Nick
jr. yeah it just would have been made
fun of it's a network from this adorable
photo bombing pug to a horse and seven
chickens it's a sweet home life for this
backstreet dad and wife Lauren but don't
expect to hear any nursery rhymes before
bed
Nick reads and sings lullabies from a
1,200 page word of the Rings book and
he's saying an elven song in the wind
from the sea the white lily sway in the
golden Tripoli I'm back Jesus I mean
this is nice here to start easy you know
some people do like good night moon I
got to make sure that he's an
intelligent oh I love that you changing
the diapers you're feeding them and
you're loving it I do not mind at all
changing diapers no everybody likes to
pee all over the place never changes it
and then he's like Oh
I wanted
a lot has changed for Nick since the
Backstreet Boys first album 20 years ago
after finishing second on season 21 of
Dancing with the Stars it looked like
the 36 year old beat his drug and
alcohol demons but then this alleged bar
brawl in January and Nick's arrest for
misdemeanor battery and in time baby
moon baby moon she's like come on have
some fun you know do what everybody else
does obviously I couldn't do what
everybody else does and for me
especially having a child now and it was
an awakening moment for me quit playing
games with my soon Nick may have to
balance fatherhood with life on the road
the Backstreet Boys tell us they are
preparing for a world tour and Nick says
there's also a Vegas residency in the
works
until then expect lots of father-son
bonding with lone Allah put him on my
chest sometimes and then he'll try to
crawl over and get mine and I'm like
this is getting awkward
take him going back to that slip-up that
Nick had in January of course I think we
can all relate we've all made mistakes
the important thing is to learn from
them and so Nick plans to go back to Key
West in July and is going to perform a
charity concert to raise money for
cancer foundation and a woman's shelter
it's important to him to turn a negative
into a positive